[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau journal a préparé par
les équipes de tv 78 nous sommes le
mercredi 8 décembre voici les titres de
cette édition
ce mercredi 8 décembre marque la journée
mondiale pour le climat objectif
rappeler l'urgence d'agir pour limiter
les effets du réchauffement climatique
vipul npns varane militants écologiques
yvelinois sera avec nous pour aborder
cette thématique cola s'engage pour une
route plus sûre une charte de prévention
vient d'être signé par l'entreprise et
la déléguée interministérielle à la
sécurité routière cet engagement parmi
lesquelles la limitation des
conversations téléphoniques au volant ou
encore le port de la ceinture de
sécurité
et puis la commanderie de saint quentin
en yvelines vous invite à son noël à
décaler un événement pour patienter
jusqu'aux fêtes de fin d'année au
programme balade botanique lantern ou
encore patinoire
[Musique]
et comme chaque année le club climat
énergie de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
organisé sa conférence autour de levier
écologique et du développement durable
sur l'agglomération élus et
entrepreneurs se sont livrés à des
débats pour discuter raisonnée et
établir une stratégie pour les
prochaines années un reportage de
bixente mayence en dise tu es belle une
cinquantaine de personnes élus et
entrepreneurs du territoire confondues
se sont réunis ce mardi 7 décembre à
l'estac à montigny le bretonneux pour la
conférence du club climat énergie et
chaque année on fait cette conférence la
en partageant vraiment les experts les
entreprises qui sont présentes sur le
territoire les élus également donc on
est vraiment dans l'action on est dans
le concret et on essaye de partage et de
voir comment on peut nous contribué
aussi à faire en sorte que nous sommes
un petit peu moins on consomme mieux je
suis assez content de voir qu'avec
l'ensemble des collègues on était
présent pour cette conférence est pour
cet événement organisé par le club
climat parce que je crois encore une
fois énormément à la relation entre les
collectivités et les entreprises je
crois que c'est ensemble qu'on arrivera
à relever les grands défis de demain
quatre débats animés pour autant de
thématiques la croissance numérique les
mobilités l'intégration du territoire ou
encore l'économie circulaire parce qu'on
est une collectivité locale lorsqu'on
est une communauté d'agglomération c'est
comment gère-t-elle achats responsables
dans mes achats publics ou tout
simplement comment j'accompagne des
l'émergence de réseaux de structures
type e ressources et ouvrir le sucre le
riz pour faire valoir la réutilisation
la réparation et le réemploi d'appareils
à destination des particuliers symbole
de cette démarche un prix de
l'innovation remis à ce qu'ils cherchent
le premier service d'autopartage
interentreprises des yvelines inauguré
en septembre 2020 à saint quentin en
yvelines on m a parlé de bouquets de
services de modalités de mobilité
concrètement c'est à dire qu'on ne met
pas tous nos oeufs dans le même panier
mais qu'on essaye d'aller sur l'ensemble
des différents modes de déplacements
possibles pour répondre aux attentes des
saint quentinois l'occasion aussi de
revenir sur une partie du programme de
2022 la mise en place de bornes de
recharge électrique supplémentaire
l'établissement du schéma directeur des
pistes cyclables et la réduction de
consommation d'énergie pour les
bâtiments à usage tertiaire
ce mercredi 8 décembre c'est la journée
mondiale du climat pour lutter contre le
changement climatique notamment et pour
aborder cette thématique avec nos vies
pullan pouvait n'être varane vous êtes
là merci d'être avec nous vous êtes un
jeune militant écologiste yves binois
puisque vous venez de marly le roi vous
avez notamment milité au sein du
mouvement used for climate est ce qu'on
peut dire que vous êtes un peu le greta
tanberg français
non je pense pas forcément c'est pas
quelque chose qui comme moi je suis un
peu en différents avis de toutes ces
considérations là
et puis justement l'une des
particularités du mouvement français qui
pour moi est particulièrement
intéressant c'est qu'on n'a pas de porte
parole ou quelqu'un qui serait au dessus
des autres qui vont à toutes les
décisions quand même eu on a un plan
mouvement horizontal c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement important et il faut que
ça reste
donc vous vous êtes engagé depuis à peu
près trois ans je crois pour la cause
écologique quelles évolutions qu'elles
soient positives ou négatives vous avez
pu observer
en termes de décisions politiques qui a
pas eu vraiment d'évolution positive
notable quoi par contre en terme de
pratiques militantes y avait des
évolutions justement le moyen de
l'histoire calme était au début on
faisait plutôt d'écrire pour le climat
et on voyait que savaient pas forcément
d'efficacité politique c'est à dire
qu'on voit grève ça marchait pas
recommencer ça marchait pas recommencer
ça marchait pas être séduite et ça ça
rejoint une idée qui pour moi est
extrêmement importante en sciences
politiques c'est que la majorité des
décideurs politiques et économiques ont
fait de grandes études et ont fui de
grandes écoles donc il connaît ça un
remaniement de la réalité de la
situation actuelle quand par exemple les
modèles macron dit qu'il n'a pas dit on
ce travail il sait qu'il y en a ils
voient les images dans animal j'en fais
tu aussi l'un des protagonistes animal
qui est le preuve le dernier film de
scierie dion qui est sorti en salle des
profs et des cendres on rencontre
justement en amber qui fait de l'élevage
intensif et qui est pris en étau par les
coopératives et d'huile 350 euros par
mois par exemple il ya de la demande ce
travail mais et de dirigeants politiques
vont ignorer une manière volontaire
parce qu'il ya des intérêts des engrais
qui sont antagonistes à ça pour tout ce
qui touche à l'écologie même si
peut-être que ya pas une philosophie qui
est extrêmement développé en
fin de nos décideurs politiques
économiques connaissent un énorme la
réalité mais l'ignorent de manière
volontaire parce que ça va contre leurs
intérêts politiques et économiques c'est
ce qui s'est aussi passé avec la
convention citoyenne pour le film à dos
il
est quasiment l'entièreté des mesures
qui avaient été proposées par le citoyen
après six mois de travail ont été vus
donc oui aujourd'hui il ya un peu il
laisse aussi de revoir une militante a
le de ces considérations
vous avez parlé documentaire on y
reviendra aussi encore une fois dans
quelques instants aujourd'hui on a un
peu dans l'urgence qu'est-ce qu'il
faudrait vous avez peut parler de
politique et de certaines mesures
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait
fondamentalement changé dans la société
pour qu'il y ait de l'espoir qu'elles
sont selon vous les priorités
aujourd'hui
sur l'espoir de je pense que déjà c'est
important de ne pas céder à la tentation
et fond de risques parce que c'est déjà
ça c'est juste soit être dans des
perspectives individualiste donc je vais
construire le coeur en plein milieu du
parc sont des modèles en récoltant du
bois et de la terre ou sinon se dire
massif où tu fasses on ne peut rien
faire donc oui aujourd'hui ce qui est
important c'est de changer la
perspective globale le récit qui
qui est en vigueur dans une société
aujourd'hui le récit en vigueur c'est la
croissance économique alors qu en soit
personne ne sait vraiment ce qu'une ce
qu'est la course ici qu économique est
ce que vous savez ce que ce qu'est la
croatie est ce que vous avez déjà un
jour rencontrer le pays mais est en fait
c'est pour sortir le débat croissance
décroissance pour d'une part avoir
d'autres indicateurs comme la santé
l'éducation qui sont beaucoup porter et
qui va le dire beaucoup plus de choses
comme l'état du monde actuel et puis
aussi ce
essayer de faire une société sans des
concepts qui aujourd'hui au mini bulle
notre monde comme par exemple la valeur
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui tous les
deux la valeur vous êtes de la valeur je
suis de la valeur les animaux en
particulier des pages qu'on n'a pas
l'air d'une forêt c'est de la valeur
la forme de la valeur qui la marchandise
tout noir de concepts comme ça qu'ils
sont devenus on apprend à la prudence
dans la prison qui sont essentielles
aujourd'hui dans notre société alors
qu'en fait ils ont un caractère
historique qui sera situé historiquement
et comprend que c'est possible de faire
sinon ça et face à ça le moi je pense
récit qu'on doit porter dans notre
société c'est ce qu'on essaie de dire à
travers animal c'est la défense vivant
manière générale humains compris jusqu'à
la prairie nous ici on est vivant
justement on va revenir sur ce
documentaire qui est un peu ce message
là vous en avez parlé tout à l'heure
c'est animal qui est sorti ce mercredi
mercredi dernier 1er décembre vous y
avez participé on y voit des extraits à
l'écran c'est un projet du réalisateur
cyril dion qu'est ce que ça vous a
apporté et plus globalement quelle est
la force de ce documentaire
moi je dis souvent que je suis un peu
passé dans mon environnementalistes en
mycologie d'entre eux début à l'aventuré
c'est à dire que l environnementalisme
pour moi ça consisterait dans une
posture on va prouver leur protéger la
nature qui serait extérieure aux humains
qui seraient essentialiser
et qui en soi est une adversaire
complices pour reprendre les termes de
pierre bourdieu de l'idéologie et du
système économique actuel qui consiste à
voir la nature comme une simple matière
inerte ex côté là une manifestation la
plus contemporaine de
l'environnementalisme c'est aussi une
forme de yarakh six nations début tout
on va considérer que justement cette
preuve la protection de cette nature qui
serait extraordinaire et la lutte aux
changements climatiques seraient
supérieurs aux autres alors qu'on soit
il ya des gens qui sont à miner et qui
meurent de plein de plus tu sais qu'il
ya un bon dieu qui disait justement que
en soit il ya une urgence qui est
intrinsèque à toute forme de lutte et à
toute forme de domination et de pouvoir
aujourd'hui il ya des gens qui meurent
de vire au travail qui vont afficher une
liste qui meurent de précarité on l'a vu
en anglais y aura aussi beaucoup en
france etc et face à l'écologie
historiquement c'est une science qui
étudie des relations à l'intérieur du
monde vivant et entre livrant à son
niveau dit donc l'écologie en tant que
l'ugtt ces luttes qui vise à repenser à
acter des relations nouvelles qui
seraient libérés et libératrice entre
lyon monument est visuellement mais
aussi à l'intérieur du vivant aimant ce
qui implique de défaire toutes les
formes de relations aliénante pour
construire de nouvelles et on peut dire
qu'un peu dans le film au début mais là
c'est un peu enfin l'autre protagoniste
du film c'est un peu la partie la
protection la nature environnante est
emma plus la partie changement
climatique de l'environnement thèse les
peuples on devient un peu tout aide des
écologistes au sens où jouent les défis
et la puissance us enfin j'espère en
tout cas que le film va aussi produire
ça chez beaucoup de gens et que ça va
aussi nous permettre de sortir de ce que
bâtiment réseau rappelle la crise de la
sensibilité c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
on a perdu toute attaque d'affaires de
concept d'histoires d'anecdotes pour
appréhender les divans du vent et lui
propose pour faire face à ça de créer
une nouvelle incursion entre une culture
des conneries tendre en partie en france
récemment il y aussi bien eu à écrire
pour le climat que notre demande que les
manifs à damas unifiée jeu plein de
trucs différents et une nouvelle culture
du vivant qui sera à créer qui serait
une nouvelle attention politique
conférait au niveau monde
peut-être une dernière petite question
puisque dans ce documentaire vous êtes
aux côtés de bella une autre jeune
militante anglaise aujourd'hui il ya
beaucoup de jeunes qui sont engagés dans
la lutte pour le climat ils ont une
grande prise de conscience est ce que
selon vous hais les jeunes ont une autre
vision une bonne et une nouvelle vision
finalement du monde à venir
là il n'y a pas forcément une
homogénéité chez les jeunes je pense et
moi je le vois et c'est pareil dans les
autres classes d'âge aussi aussi je
pense justement le fils doit prendre le
réalisateur du film cité siricu appauvri
style élément n'est pas de la même
catégorie en termes d'âge quoi
donc je pense qu'il ya des gens qui sont
un peu engagé dans toutes les classes
d'âge mais qu' il ya peut-être quelque
chose de plus fort chez les jeunes
générations étant donné qu'il ya un peu
cette perception que savoir encore sans
doute en plus nous embarque nous
impacter que les autres générations mais
je pense qu'il faut faire attention à ne
pas trop parler de la fracture
générationnelle parce qu'il ya presque
en effet un peu performatif incréé
d'autant plus cette pointure
canton quand on en parle et qui en fait
aussi une autre fracture qui est la
fracture sociale et qui pour moi
d'autant plus marquante est importante
parce que a priori si dans des lieux
dans des espaces écologiques comme des
jardins ouvriers ou des fleurs à
l'évolution des réseaux solidarité on va
trouver un peu des gens de tous les âges
on va pas après pas trouvé les gens qui
sont à l'origine des destructions et
c'est à dire par exemple pdg de total ou
présente un joli coup est innocent tôt
merci beaucoup vie pleine pouvait n'être
varane d'avoir été avec nous je le
rappelle vous êtes militant écologiste
merci beaucoup
[Musique]
côté transports demain le trafic sur le
rer b sera perturbé plusieurs syndicats
dont la cgt cheminots ont appelé les
conducteurs de la ligne et plus
largement les salariés de la sncf
concernés à faire grève ce jeudi 9
décembre un mouvement social local pour
dénoncer une dégradation de leurs
conditions de travail ils revendiquent
notamment une hausse de leurs salaires
demain 4 trains sur 5 sont prévus en
heure de pointe trois sur quatre en
heures creuses rendez vous sur les site
transilien.com rer b le blog ou encore
sur le site de la ratp pour connaître
l'impact sur vos trajets
et je vous le disais en titre
l'entreprise colas filiale du groupe
bouygues a accueilli ce mercredi 8
décembre sur son campus scientifique et
technique la déléguée interministérielle
à la sécurité routière avec le pdg de la
société qui est implantée à magny les
hameaux elle a signé cet engagement pour
une route plus sûre une charte destinée
aux collabos la aux collaborateurs
l'occasion aussi de découvrir les
innovations de l'entreprise spécialisée
dont les infrastructures routières le
reportage de nicolas landry c'est une
tradition au sein de l'entreprise colas
l'engagement pour une route plus sûre
depuis 1997 la filiale de bouygues
signent une charte avec la délégation
interministérielle à la sécurité
routière plus de 400 collaborateurs de
colas désigné relais sécurité routière
sont engagés sur ce sujet nous on est
soixante mille personnes en groupe les
soixante mille personnes sont en contact
permanent avec ce que nous faisons en
sécurité routière et c'est quelque chose
qui s'arrête pas quand petit le travail
quand ils reviennent chez eux dans leur
vie privée ils continuent à avoir ce
réflexe et c'est comme ça pour qu'on
peut créer ou sans effet boule de neige
pour harry arriver à améliorer la
sécurité routière partout limitée aux
cas d'urgence les conversations
téléphoniques rappelé l'exigence du port
de la ceinture ou encore le bridage de
la vitesse des véhicules des actions
pour sensibiliser les collaborateurs de
colas aujourd'hui la délégation
interministérielle à la sécurité
routière a déjà signé avec 1800
entreprises représentant plus de 3
millions de salariés l'insécurité
routière c'est la première cause de
mortalité travail et ensuite parce que
eh bien justement les accidents liés au
travail correspondent à une part
importante des accidents sur la route
spécialisée dans les infrastructures
routières les équipes recherche et
développement de colas ont pu présenter
les dernières innovations en lien avec
la sécurité routière notamment la
solution de marquage au sol lumineuse ce
qui paraît particulièrement utile
notamment pour protéger des usagers
vulnérables dans le cadre de passage
piéton ou de voix cyclistes notamment
donc nous allons regarder avec colle
assez bien ce qu'il propose avec son
engagement pour la sécurité routière
colas a réduit de plus de 75% le taux de
fréquence des accidents routiers
professionnels
favoriser l'économie circulaire et
inciter au zéro déchet voici les
objectifs de l'entreprise yvelinoise ma
bonne étoile lancée en 2013 par un
couple vernoliens la société
commercialise des gourdes de compote
réutilisables mais pas que les
explications de mathilde francou
c'est à verneuil-sur-seine qu'elisabeth
et nicholas ou blé ont décidé d'établir
le siège de leur entreprise
ma bonne étoile depuis 2013 il
commercialise des mini gourde de compote
réutilisables les squeeze bonne étoile
c'est vraiment une histoire de famille
avec le polar la cinq enfants et puis un
jour on va regarder autour de nous
surtout notre cuisine et on s'est rendu
compte qu'on j'étais énormément
d'emballage à usage unique
et particulièrement il y avait un
produit que je n'avais pas supprimer
c'étaient les petits bourgs de compote
face à ce constat le couple se lance
dans la création de leur propre
entreprise
depuis la naissance de ce quiz ses 90
millions de gourdes jetables qui ont été
économisés on est sur une bourde qui qui
ressemble tout à fait à une gourde
jetables à la différence près que le
front s'ouvre et que tu peux remplir
deux fois de plus compote en gros
beaucoup comme ça soit de compote fait
maison mais aussi de purée de smoothie
autres innovations de l'entreprise les
bento feel good permettant d'emporter
son déjeuner n'importe où c'est le ji
boks ont fabriqué à partir de plastique
végétal on est parti sur une solution
vegetal chair qu'on utilise un
polyéthylène qui à base de sucre de
canne ça permet de réduire finalement
l'utilisation de matières fossiles
depuis 2015 ma bonne étoile et certifié
bicorne un label qui reconnaît les
efforts environnementaux et les effets
bénéfiques de l'entreprise dans le monde
mais la société souhaite dorénavant
toucher plus de monde et atteindre les
clients de la grande distribution avec
proust
[Musique]
on va arriver en grande distribution
donc supermarchés hypermarchés un autre
objectif de l'entreprise yvelinoise
s'étendre à l'international
on va aller chercher d'autres marchés à
l'international
qui n'étaient pas forcément très mature
sur ce type de produits exemple
l'amérique du nord outre la france ma
bonne étoile distribue ses produits en
suisse aux pays-bas en belgique et en
allemagne où elle réalise 35% de son
chiffre d'affaires
un petit mot de football à présent cet
après-midi une convention de partenariat
a été signée entre le fo plaisir et le
red star fc 93 que le professionnel qui
évolue en national l'événement a pris
place au stade bernard giroux de plaisir
une signature en présence du directeur
sportif steve marlet ancien joueur passé
par fulham en angleterre lyon et
marseille et nous explique l'intérêt de
ce partenariat au micro de bixente mais
rien senti steban sur l'aspect sportif
c'est intéressant mais c'est pas que
c'est aussi des échanges avec les
éducateurs nous le but c'est de
d'ouvrir le club à tous les départements
et de l'ouvrir à des clubs qui nous
ressemble qu'ils ressentent dans la
dynamique de structuration c'est le cas
avec avec plaisir est dans l'adn
notamment ce qu'ils transmettent ce
qu'ils veulent transmettre aux jeunes ce
qu'ils font en dehors aussi du football
c'est une très grande fierté c'est vrai
que mon opus le reste car c'est un club
de la région parisienne club historique
ça nous permettent de continuer nos
structures et
du 1er au 15 décembre la commanderie de
saint quentin en yvelines vous invite à
son noël est décalé objectif vous faire
plonger dans la magie de noël pour vous
faire patienter avant les fêtes de fin
d'année à de multiples activités sont
proposées sont aarhus balade botanique
ou encore lanterne flottante nouveauté
de cette année la patinoire se tiendra
dont la chapelle patrick jacques de
dixmude et mathilde francon musique
éclatante lumière disco la chapelle de
la commanderie a enfilé son costume de
fête pour le noël décalé de la
commanderie ouverte le mercredi samedi
et dimanche la patinoire installée pour
l'occasion offre aux enfants et à leurs
parents un moment de partage et de
sourire dans une ambiance animée
par ici apprend la danse en tous sens
j'aime bien parce que c'est
ça glisse
c'est semble assez chouette c'est très
bien organisé et réserver par internet
un super accueil et xativa est très
bonne puisque c'est d'activités qu'on
n'a pas l'habitude de faire on n'a pas
de patinoire dans le secteur ça permet
de les occuper en temps d'hiver c'est
difficile trouvaient ses activités
[Musique]
le calendrier des activités va s'étoffer
dans les jours à venir que vous vouliez
écouter de la musique vous exercez en
stop-motion fabriquer des savons ou
encore vous amuser avec un manège
l'heure est à la découverte et à la
convivialité en attendant les fêtes on a
un banias mobile
on a donc l'espace dans lequel on se
trouve qui sera donc qui est un espace
de détente scénographiée par deux
artistes on aura une fanfare qui sera là
samedi et puis donc les ateliers
d'angers parler de création et y aura
notamment un atelier de lanternes ou y
aura une mise à l'eau des lanternes le
marché des créateurs locaux et des
associations solidaires aura lieu quant
à lui le week-end des 11 et 12 décembre
un reportage réalisé avec ses dunes
charlet et célia gars tsongo c'est la
fin de ce journal merci à tous de nous
avoir suivi dans un instant retrouver
mélanie poké à la présentation de votre
7,8 société très bonne soirée à tous sur
tv 78
[Musique]